hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I am your co-host
Geo and I'm BART to the quiz Zone to the
croissant to the croissant Quiznos
um speaking of croissant makes me think
of baked goods which makes me think of
how bomb and cozy
um and and and delicious the house
smells which then makes me think of
the holidays and we're like deep in the
holiday season right now as you can tell
I'm wearing my home alone shirt are you
a uh Christmas decorations goes up after
Halloween person yeah or after
Thanksgiving person Thanksgiving doesn't
exist thanks to giving go away and I'll
be absolutely happy like can we start
thanks I mean can we start Christmas on
November 1st like it just the world just
feels better I kind of wished
um Halloween was Tearaway pants for
Christmas Halloween was Tearaway pants
for Christmas why what do you mean so
you know Tearaway pants yeah the NBA
it's like they shoot
warm boom shorts underneath
I wished it was like to deck to properly
decorate your house you put Snow candy
canes Christmas lights you put all that
up right yeah and then you put the
spooky ghost on top and then you put
like coffins over and the minute
trick-or-treating is done boom take that
off and
foreign
I wish
we could just get rid of Halloween too
not really no Halloween's fun what about
the kids and all the kids I grew up with
my my eldest sister being [ __ ]
obsessed like
obsessed with [ __ ] Halloween that's
also weird why because that means you're
like the Tim Burton of the group yeah I
mean people love scary movies so what's
wrong with that yeah there's a
difference between liking scary movies
yeah
versus the this guy at Subway
normal and like like stuff right you
know what I'm saying like let's say
you're really into spicy food and you go
to the restaurant and go yo oh give me
the spicy food but if you're the guy
with the necklace and a chili pepper
dude that's weird man that is weird
right but it also depends on who it is
right like let's say Anthony Bourdain
had the [ __ ] Chili Pepper he's like a
fashion icon now right like now you're
gonna be like that [ __ ] made
Chili's so dope I think it just depends
on the person yeah that's their industry
right but if you're like like your
sister regular job like if she was uh
works at a haunted house or a Halloween
store and you go to her house and it's
like purple Ghouls and all that stuff
cool I get it but if she's like
overzealous with [ __ ] cauldrons and
[ __ ] like when Halloween comes around
that's the weird guy a Subway why is
that weird no it's not okay first of all
when do you think my sister starts
decorating like in [ __ ] January
it's not the time
it's how all out they go well what's all
out for you because she just decorates
like she's not doing anything more than
that and she just I don't like where
this is going because you talk [ __ ]
about your sister [ __ ] you and I got
your back and now you are being a
Benedict Arnold I am not what the [ __ ] I
just said my sister just Falcon loves it
and that I was going into you were gonna
but you're saying in a way where she
[ __ ] is unacceptable no I was saying
it because I think I got such a [ __ ]
uh uh uh uh [ __ ] like crazy exposure
to Halloween like all my life because
she's 15 years older than me so I could
never Escape it that I'm like this [ __ ]
I am for me like I just knew at a very
early age that I just didn't give a [ __ ]
about Halloween besides the fact that
you get a [ __ ] ton of candy does she
have a smoke machine in her front yard a
hundred percent that's kind of cool
actually
oh my God no because like At first I was
thinking about I'm like oh best little
[ __ ] with the [ __ ] smoke machine
and then I imagine walking into the
house with the smoke machine I'm like
that's damn that's pretty cool yeah no
she loves that [ __ ]
um so yeah early on I was like and that
[ __ ] ain't for me and then did she eat
Abba zabas
what the [ __ ] are Abba zabbas you
[ __ ] dinosaurs what is it called the
ones that black and yellow wrapping
don't bring that up Tim Tim somewhere
heard this [ __ ] black and yellow okay
fun fact
um yeah
um he [ __ ] loves that video last name
his 24 letter last name yeah
um every year without a fail he [ __ ]
sends me the black and yellow [ __ ]
music video I know and I think he
legitimately finds it cute because like
he like obviously he loves us he's our
friend but like he finds it cute or you
think he finds a cringe both I think
because he loves us he finds it cute I
find a cringe 100 but every time it's so
cringy I can't even see those colors
together because I'm like oh yeah [ __ ]
I'm wearing it right now I should have
been cringing for me it's like it there
it was that period of YouTube where you
try anything and everything you did
everything you know and so there wasn't
no like fashion haul or a cooks or you
know no there was black and yellow
currency it was like everyone did
whatever and he just tried and
experienced and messed around yeah
everyone was trying to make I mean not
everyone could be like a Kev jemba like
Nigahiga with like
millions of dollars so everyone was just
let's see what we can do to go back
throw some [ __ ] at the wall and see what
sticks but yeah so going back to the
holidays um yeah so then uh Thanksgiving
rolls around and we weren't really like
a super United Family so like this was
the only time the entire year that there
was an excuse that my mom my dad and
everyone sits at the table my mom busted
out the Good China I didn't even know
there was like a thing of like regular
like um dishes and then just like the
good kind of like actual silverware it's
supposed to be silver yeah like I now I
like really appreciated it but like or
appreciate it because back in the day
like when we were gonna like the week of
the the Thanksgiving dinner prep she
would bust out this wooden ass box it's
a beautiful box oh and then we open it
up and it's these Rusty ass [ __ ]
silverware because it's real silver yeah
so I would have to meet Direction it's
tarnished
would it oh tarnish you're right it's
not Russ [ __ ] [ __ ] you're that kid in
school I know a lot about nothing and I
know nothing about a lot so we're at the
same place yeah this is why you're my
soulmate
um and yeah this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
tarnished and black as [ __ ] and there I
was [ __ ] polishing what do you do use
CLR or you used no no there's like a
silver polish one Russell or something I
I mean I don't I don't read so it was
just like a black bottle and like it's
like this blue I don't know this is I'm
also talking about like yeah it goes 20
years ago and then when you wipe it the
other way it's like it was beautiful
yeah so
um I looked forward to that because that
was like the first time my family would
really get together however once we're
all at the table that's when the drama
[ __ ] kicks off because my dad starts
talking [ __ ] to my brother my brother
starts talking [ __ ] to my sister my
sister she's talking [ __ ] to everybody
my mom's trying to calm everyone down
it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] show is it one
of those things where everyone
has already like moved on to live where
they're supposed to live and then they
come together that too or is it there
that you guys are still in the same well
I mean as the years progress that would
happen right like they would start
bringing in their significant others a
boyfriend the girlfriend or whatever and
then it would be like the husband and
the wife
um I mean now we're not as United as we
once were and obviously rip my papa's
past but wait mine too
laughs
got that in common now so
far
okay
this is the first time you hear that
music please watch the last video the
last episode yeah I'm sorry just just if
you're not in the right mental state to
listen to to some sad [ __ ] don't listen
to it but yeah basically
RP to our puppets yeah um but yeah so
that was the only reason why I like
Thanksgiving I was just kind of like
whatever but Christmas bruh Christmas
was my [ __ ] did you guys ever uh do
Pilgrims and Indians in like Elementary
School 100 dude when I was going to
school like you know the crisscross
applesauce yeah we would call that [ __ ]
sit Indian style yeah we would pledge
allegiance to the flags the United
States of America
um to which it stands either but like
the [ __ ] you know we're supposed to
have children I kind of missed all that
I mean you don't miss that
um I think because it's nostalgic for
you and it was like a good time because
now it's like insulting to people right
yeah well the the term Indian giver
remember that [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ]
well there weren't any Indian givers at
Thanksgiving that I knew of
well I don't know just just terms right
and like kind of like
passed on from generation to generation
thought behind it because you know how
like you used to make your own like I
can't believe that was a term what a
[ __ ] up term being Giver [ __ ] off but
I didn't even get pissed you Indian
giver you gave that to me yeah I didn't
I don't even know what that meant like I
didn't even know what an Indian was to
be honest with you so like I'm not
talking about elementary school you know
how that one there's that one like phase
in elementary where you know the Burger
King crowns but pretty much like you
make your own yeah right yeah so like we
it would be the class would be perfectly
divided into pilgrims and Indians and
what was crazy is like um my classrooms
were perfectly if you're white you kind
of just gravitated towards the pilgrims
it's horrible and then all minorities
whether you're black Indian like Native
American Indian or East Asian in or a
South Asian Indian or Asian or Mexican
everyone was just the Indians and we
loved it we no one was like offended by
it yeah how old are you
probably like seven or something yeah no
[ __ ] your history books were talking
about Columbus [ __ ] sitting down so
what I'm saying you're going like hey
let's all have a [ __ ] dinner together
so what I remember of how the year used
to end like I looked forward to the year
ending because I knew it was going to
end in three bangers we're gonna get
Halloween but that's not where the year
ends we're gonna be talking about
Thanksgiving the year doesn't end like
and then we're gonna have a school year
or calendar year just the life year or
is it in your brain year we knew we're
gonna have three bangers yeah yeah yeah
and from my life four bangers you know
that well hold on a second and then from
my life
slowly one of the bangers started like
not getting as much radio play
and that's Thanksgiving and I'm like if
we could bring that back some way where
as adults if we show up to our
Thanksgiving friendsgiving dinners in
Indian or Pilgrim outfits
that would be sick and we made it a
bigger thing you know what I mean no I'm
good imagine going why though it's such
a [ __ ] tragic holiday it was the
holiday where they that's Harmony true
oh I don't care about the truth I care
about what we're trying to sell like it
sounds like you don't want to stay true
fine you can do that but just just focus
on the thanks
and the giving part of it not the
[ __ ] old school ancient half [ __ ]
well I want to see the pilgrims like
imagine we go to Marie Calendars and
then you got pilgrims there with those
leather boots I'd be pissed and then you
got Indians and then you know I'd be
[ __ ] pissed you know chicks want any
reason to hold the [ __ ] out which ones
would they be the pilgrims so they're
gonna Hull out in some Pocahontas
looking outfit yeah no I'd be pissed
that's gonna be so dumb I feel so
[ __ ] pissed why I'd be like what the
[ __ ]
no and then we're going to get our
Banger back
why would why why not do that right now
right now we just got two bangers we got
one Banger and then one random song that
the DJ sneaks in yeah because now we
know what the truth was right like we
all know I don't even know what the
truth is tell me the truth well okay so
um when we learn about Columbus and
stuff he's like obviously it's all going
to depend on who's writing the [ __ ]
history books right yeah they're always
going to be the [ __ ] Victors and the
good guys but unfortunately
um I mean now that we live in a state
and in a manly a [ __ ] country where
it's like a Melting Pot of just so many
diverse cultures and peoples and
traditions and stuff
um Native American history is pretty
[ __ ] of course all history is pretty
[ __ ] but at least in this country it's
it's pretty sad
so why are you putting the vibe down
[ __ ]
I'm talking about how to have a [ __ ]
Banger of a year
you're talking about I'm sorry man I
have a heart dude whoa it's like you're
doing like yo look at that [ __ ]
new [ __ ] Jordans bro what I'm gonna
talk about the kids yeah
I'm like which kids that God I got these
for 400 off stockx okay that's all I
care about why you gotta bring the vibe
yeah I'm not trying to do a banger like
that like let's just stick the [ __ ]
costumes in the Halloween we can just be
thankful and have our friends giving
[ __ ] and create our own things
in the middle of November I missed that
no I was just explaining to you how I
don't give a [ __ ] about Halloween or
Thanksgiving and my jam is
you only care about having one bang or a
month a year no I got two bangers bro
what's the other one [ __ ] my birthday
that's the bangers or the bangers no one
cares about that one you don't [ __ ]
care about that one I have to no [ __ ]
but the rest of the world don't
celebrate it together I got a friend my
mom buys me a cake she remembers yeah
but she visited her little Kelly they
don't turn ice skating rinks into any
festivities for you I'm humble all right
if I wasn't humble I would fight really
hard to get my birthday because I don't
even give a [ __ ] about my birth my
birthday I wonder why in terms of the
other bangers you know what Give me the
give me your best [ __ ] childhood
birthday memory go my best childhood
birthday
best or weird or funnest no best
reason why I specific
the word best
I don't have any memory no [ __ ] [ __ ]
Bart Bart there it is that's one
literally why you don't give a [ __ ]
about your birthday ask me the same
question
I feel sorry for Morgan pay car for
Morgan pay car if you ever watch this I
miss you you're happening what's
happening and I'm sorry my mom made you
do homework
go go what is it give it to me I never
had any um bangers uh birthdays birthday
bangers right yeah so now do you wonder
why you don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about
your birthday no but it's still not a
banger because it's not like a worldwide
thing well it's not gonna be a banger
because no one made it a banger for you
but you even your birthday's not a bang
and you've been trying to [ __ ]
celebrate every year my birthday's a
banger for me
for you but you don't you don't go into
a Home Depot
signs and [ __ ] I'm humble dude what does
that mean I don't want to see that
just as long as I'm having a good time
and every everyone I love is celebrating
me
um it's a banger party I think you're
more of a solo masturbator I like Circle
Jerks
oh I want a circle jerk with a lot of
people and then that's a banger I don't
want to do no solo masturbation the way
you do oh okay well then then stick to
your Thanksgiving
wait wait let's talk about uh well
what's his name Morgan pay car yeah what
happened with him well he did grow a
mustache in sixth grade which is pretty
nuts too
sixth grade what are you 11 that is
pretty gnarly he was a man I could have
swore this full of six two a six points
but uh but you were probably like what
[ __ ] three nine I was little yeah but
in fifth grade um I've been begging my
parents every year to have a birthday
party
so my mom was like okay you get to have
one of course Her Style
so she wanted a dress code where it's
like hey we gotta shut up we gotta be
like you know it's like a a
more than usual event it's a gentleman
[ __ ] black tiger so she had me
[ __ ] wear a dress shirt and slacks
the whole time what about everyone else
I think she put that out there and kids
just came in their clothes like shorts
and a t-shirt yeah who the [ __ ] owns
[ __ ] like that yeah I have probably like
five or six friends that came over most
of them went to my school I think one of
them uh lived across the street
um because by this time already kicked
it got kicked out a bunch of schools so
I have friends from different places
she thought all the parents were going
to be so happy and thankful if she made
everyone do math homework
so we did math homework together
and then for lunch my mom made like
vegetarian food which tastes nasty I I'm
sure like my mom's been uh dabbling and
vegetarian science culinary arts for 20
years she hasn't mastered it and it's I
now so imagine like 10 15 years ago it's
still in the experimental phases
and then
um after that she wanted all of us take
a nap
we're all 10 years old you know and then
um yeah all my friends are just like
I can't believe I gave up my Saturday
for this yeah I would hate Morgan was
one of the dudes that came
and but why why did you single him out
why not everyone else why didn't you
shout everyone else out and apologize to
them I forgot everyone else's name okay
fair if I remember Morgan and I remember
another guy named Dennis shout out to
Morgan and Dennis
um and I do remember that Morgan and
Dennis are practicing WWE during the
little free time that we had oh and then
uh Morgan kind of like twisted his leg
and I used my boy scout skills and I ran
into the freezer grabbed some ice cream
and I put on his hamstring to ice it
but that was a very weird flex but uh
cool but it was a pretty bad
birthday yeah I mean I get why they're
not bangers I get it
um so why not stick to Thanksgiving
and do a friend's giving
if we all get to wear Pilgrim and Indian
outfits why why do you need an outfit
you don't even like wearing anything
beside like the fact that you're dressed
up right now is a miracle well this is
not fun
wearing a Pilgrim's outfit
um why did you wear that for Halloween
then you don't give a [ __ ] about
Halloween either
I think I would care more about
Thanksgiving more than Halloween why
what's the difference pilgrims and
Indians I mean you can do that freely I
mean
you could try to do that I don't know if
I could wear a Pilgrim's outfit on a
regular and then be okay with it not a
regular I said Halloween
they're gonna twist it
what do you mean like imagine being
Santa Claus on Halloween that's actually
pretty funny they're gonna whoop their
ass no one will up your ass you're gonna
be like oh that's pretty good
okay yeah you never thought about that
no because I want to do like I'm I'm not
the type of person to like wear Knight's
armor
to like
like Raging Waters okay are you
yeah but I don't I don't I don't I can't
draw I like to stay in my Lane right if
I'm gonna wear Knights armor I'm gonna
stay at medieval knights it's gonna be I
mean if you want to stay in your lane
I mean you're celebrating the wrong
holidays in bro no but I'm in America
some American all right so as an
American
I want to eat turkey
with cranberry you do not want to eat
[ __ ] turkey you're a turkey guy yup
and I want to have some ham I want to
have some candy dabs and marshmallows in
a Pilgrim's outfit or an Indian outfit
[ __ ] go back to the turkey or the
ham which one do you prefer depends on
who made it and how it's done
oh have you ever had fried turkey no I
heard it's delicious [ __ ] I hear it
every year and I think we've even talked
about that's why I only can imagine
because ham to me it's like you [ __ ] it
up it's still good you really good
you know yeah like it's like this no
it's not it is no it's not have you ever
had turkey like fresh out the oven and
it's juicy still it's good you just
can't let it sit for very long I mean
you've given me turkey from like all
walks of [ __ ] culinary life yeah and
I've never been like God damn I'm blown
away this turkey is a [ __ ] to be honest
turkey's not that great no [ __ ] so
turkey or ham
I think ham is the [ __ ] it's her babe
it's she's the [ __ ] hot chick that
everyone wants to bonus shut the [ __ ]
I'm too available you get a sliced up
Oscar Meyer yeah no [ __ ] and next to the
ham guess what you see [ __ ] turkey
you get the breast like that's [ __ ]
indecent exposure there's nobody no one
buying turkey though oh he bites her all
the time no not the slicer you get
ground turkey we get turkey all the time
sliced turkey too we do yeah but when I
eat it's readily available for and
everyone guesses everyone finger bangs a
[ __ ] turkey too dude but when I make
it I still call it a ham sandwich why
would you do that because it's sliced up
why not call it baloney
oh below it tastes good oh
so you're
bologna tastes better than ham way
better shut the [ __ ] up
oh the best ham the candied [ __ ] ham
with the pineapples and [ __ ] from Honey
Baked it's like here right the shittiest
ham I've ever tasted is here like Ham's
just ham yeah you can't go wrong because
it can't go wrong
no you can
because it doesn't it's like the person
that's like
okay this guy crushed it in this game he
scored like one point but he does really
bad he scored zero points no no it's
Kobe ham is Kobe of the [ __ ] deli
meats nah yes you can't go turkey is
Kobe because no because if turkey is
done is anyone else listening to this
[ __ ] turkey not turkey's done good it's
crazy exactly and this is and guess what
how many is and if Kobe isn't on the
court you feel
no [ __ ] so that's no turkey could
disappear and people for [ __ ] five
honestly if um during the [ __ ] covid
shortages and [ __ ] if Turkey never
appeared again I think people now would
probably be like hey what's that one
white meat that we used to get that like
is dry as [ __ ] and tastes like cardboard
oh
turkey that's what people would do you
know that's the funniest theme during
coven
oh [ __ ] what
after I said that [ __ ] I was like God
damn it where's barking to take this no
no this is because you know like
pre-covet when we're still like on our
high horses and privilege and Privileges
and luxuries right
I want plant-based this and I'll eat
there's really bad because I'm gonna
have the quinoa or whatever right like
everyone's like oh I'm so health
conscious like only go to like sprouts
and Whole Foods whatever right and then
like everyone's like oh yeah whatever
like that's that's what you're used to
claim your lifestyle is but when [ __ ]
hits the [ __ ] fan and I remember
remember there's like two milk maximum
per household like two steak minimum one
toilet paper thing because we didn't
know we thought it was gonna be
shortages you go to the supermarket all
red meat gonzos right everything was
[ __ ] all full plan [ __ ]
[ __ ] stocks right regular white rice
gonzos [ __ ] quinoa and [ __ ]
cauliflower rice yeah cauliflower rice
what's the other one that's there's
another [ __ ] [ __ ] thing
all up in there [ __ ] chickpeas or
whatever they're fully stocked yeah and
it's like dude when it comes down to it
like let's just all be real we all
whether we like it or not I mean whether
we eat it on the regular or not or
whether it's healthy or not or whatever
we know what's bomb and what we like
yeah yeah and we don't need to be
[ __ ] fake about it you know you don't
think it's because they're just they're
probably more the the greater population
is on a like a on a meat based diet no
because if you're talking about survival
where we have to ration [ __ ] out
um nothing is safe
like you ever been to the field with a
bunch of Marines you're asking me if
I've ever been yeah yeah I have you know
I've had wild college nights you go to
the field with a bunch of Marines okay
after a good like three to five days
there is nothing left of anyone's MRE uh
you're saying MREs because those are
[ __ ] absolute trash that's [ __ ]
nasty some of them are good but but good
is MRE good yeah
yeah nothing's awesome you said yeah
right Chili's yeah yeah you said yeah
right no I said like turkey good and
you're like yeah no turkey is really
good are you talking no no like turkey
good I get it just use the analogies I
understand okay fine but like MREs it's
like that right and but when [ __ ] hits
the fan yeah yeah everything's survival
mode all that shit's [ __ ] gone yeah
you start eating grass and [ __ ] you're
like exactly so even when people are so
what America's told me through the
canvas of Albertsons is that even when I
die I'd rather not eat that quinoa
[ __ ] fine I mean that's how you took
it I just took it as there's just less
vegetarians and vegans in this world
even the canned goods you could tell
like okay people really like [ __ ]
SpaghettiOs they [ __ ] do you like
SpaghettiOs hey can artichokes or
whatever the [ __ ] that is whoa take it
easy what did artichokes do to you those
are bomb maybe to you but I'm just
saying like it's pretty clear what
people like yeah when [ __ ] hits the fan
yeah garbage absolute garbage but it's
still the best seller you know that's
what I'm saying I mean
and that's what I liked about covid
because you can you can [ __ ] go
around you have to do your research yeah
you can go around saying what you want
what you believe but at the end of the
day the results are the facts the
results are the facts got it what did
you get from people taking all the
[ __ ] toilet paper
I thought people were dumb as [ __ ]
I'm like bro how many shits are you
gonna take I'm like if [ __ ] is about to
hit the fan yeah I'm not wiping my ass
anymore you don't really think she's so
there's two levels of fan of fan
[ __ ] right or [ __ ] Fannin or [ __ ]
hitting [ __ ] hitting fan [ __ ] hidden
one is
are we still cool man to man
you know are we still in this Society in
this Brotherhood in the citizenship this
communal uh vow that we have to each
other is that still being uphealth
if that's being upheld for me I would
think everyone that's grabbed water we
need to just everyone stay alive right
you can as long as you have water clean
water you can still survive for seven
days
that's the that's like [ __ ] hits the fan
right here if [ __ ] hits the fan fan
where we are no longer Brothers
there's no such thing as country as
patriotism infrastructure is down this
is [ __ ]
um
what's that zombie like TV show Everyone
likes uh Walking Dead like Walking Dead
then like how you talked about it as if
it's still like going on oh I mean it is
probably
um for me
what everyone should be buying is
bullets
because now Whoever has the most bullets
is King
because if I have bullets I can take
your candy damps your ham
probably even your daughter if I wanted
to God damn you know what I'm saying wow
talk about the [ __ ] Vibe killing what
Jesus so your [ __ ] bullets kill the
vibe bro I told you I'm a [ __ ]
Pilgrim
oh my God you see what I'm saying
you make my [ __ ] head hurt I'm a
[ __ ] Pilgrim [ __ ] oh my God
and you know what pilgrims do you're
absolute trash if I get to be a pilgrim
for Thanksgiving no it's not happening
I'm gonna go to [ __ ] a [ __ ]
David's house with a [ __ ] musket on
my back
is
and then after every meal I'm gonna
[ __ ] put a little bit of pellet and
gunpowder like that
but why David
it's for friends friendsgiving all right
all right but yeah that's why during the
whole cover thing I was just like
watching people's behavior I'm like no
one even damn this this world is sad no
one even knows how to survive number one
because these are the two things that
you should be getting if we believe in
this we're going to be in this together
we're still a team we are man to man
we're both Americans we've got this
together Mark right then water that
should be completely gone toilet paper
you could [ __ ] clean your ass with
your fingers if you needed to right yeah
I mean hey I've had a kid I have no
problem
if you have no more belief in the
country now it's just strictly survival
and now we are all animals that just
know how to Flap gums
then bro bullets because now it's my
tribe your tribe and um this is how
we're gonna have to stay alive you know
and that's how um you're gonna stay
alive I mean that's how all these these
all these other tribes do it all over
all right all right let me take it back
to [ __ ] Christmas all right you just
I you brought the vibe down dude I did I
was really thinking about like all of
the [ __ ] decorations and I've been
watching me and Tech I've been watching
a lot of um home alone
I have like the [ __ ] soundtrack in my
brain
yeah that's it
um and all I think about is like the
greens and the Reds and I'm so stoked
and I just can't wait like I'm
salivating to talk about [ __ ]
Christmas and all the [ __ ] that I love
about it and here you go talking about
[ __ ] I don't know wiping [ __ ] with
your hands
so can we talk about Christmas please I
mean that's just being real
have you ever watched this [ __ ]
I never have
that's why people that do that are
disgusting oh my god I've never done
that have you and I've been in some like
really sticky situations
never never had to I either I always had
the worst ever well I don't know if this
is worse what's worse
but definitely okay what's worse to you
would you rather
wipe your [ __ ] with your hands
or dig in the trash
find a clean part of someone else's [ __ ]
paper
and wipe your ass with that
you did
um and and am I out in the wild or am I
with among civilians and like in a
civilian setting like in a bathroom the
wild of Taipei
you guys still have [ __ ] bathrooms in
the ground like I don't you have to
[ __ ] worse which one's worse which
one's worse what do you get no [ __ ]
under your fingernails I'll do that for
real [ __ ] yeah I don't know what [ __ ]
diseases someone else's Savage reason
but it's my own [ __ ] I know what I'm
consuming I'm controlling the Civilized
[ __ ] you don't tell me you [ __ ] dug
in the trash you piece of [ __ ] and you
got someone else's [ __ ] paper and wipe
their ass with [ __ ] paper
it was the clean parts
it was the clean part of it all right
okay were you wearing socks that day
did you have underwear on
I think that was
that they've already been taken care of
beforehand no what does that mean I
probably use them already no you didn't
I probably did no you didn't I think I
remember this story and I and I recall
going why didn't you just use your
[ __ ] sock and you were like I didn't
think about it oh no or maybe I was in
Taiwan and you know it's human you need
your socks
it was in Taiwan actually because then
your feet are gonna just like [ __ ]
because I've I've ran into that
predicament myself public restroom
didn't have anything I did see the
[ __ ] the the trash filled with all of
the because every stall had a little
trash can so I was just looking down I'm
like
[ __ ] this is nasty but yeah
um so what I did was I wrecked I
recognized I had two socks on and I was
like okay
let me do the math here
um grab someone else's ship paper
that's way too much like there's just
too many risks involved with that I
never once considered using my hand ever
I
so then I was like all right what else
do I got to play with and I was like
uh-huh
socks you don't have socks if I don't
have socks the next is my underwear okay
let's see you don't have socks in under
what do you do uh sports bra I'm always
wearing a sports bra okay let's say no
sports bra no socks no under what do you
do that's already so many options you're
just making it the worst why wouldn't I
be wearing that
let's say you're in Hawaii okay you're
in a swimsuit oh that's a good one you
gotta go dookie
um I would take off my bra rip if I wear
the padding in it probably take the
padding out use that okay if that's not
an option then there's another lining
that holds the padding in between the
the bra and then the other side so
there's like a pocket right those are
two pieces of fabric I'd rip the inside
fabric out I have Solutions okay there's
also another lining part here that's
supposed to in the crotch of the bikini
I'd rip that [ __ ] out too like I have
[ __ ] options what else we think
so different no [ __ ] I'm not about to
[ __ ] use someone else's [ __ ] paper I
just shot in the ocean
[Laughter]
but what if what if it comes back to you
no you gotta swim away you gotta know
what's going on what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
I shot in the ocean maybe like two years
ago okay I think Taiko was with me oh I
swam off to the side I was like oh if I
got a [ __ ] and I was like either I walk
on the hot ass hand go and go all the
way over there and you know how much the
sand pulls you in Hawaii it takes you
forever I'm like or I can just [ __ ] in
the water I'm gonna pee in the water
anyways so I swam off to where I was by
myself and then I uh pulled my pants
down down to my knees good for you and I
open my butt cheeks so that I had the
least amount of spirit all the [ __ ]
fish someone like this and then I just
pushed it
I pushed it and then I immediately just
started kicking away so I don't so the
poop doesn't come near me okay stick my
finger in my butt and then I do the
thing and I cleaned it all up I pulled
it out of the water look I was like whoa
that's very clean
done done easy
okay well okay and I didn't have to
sacrifice nothing I'd have to tear off
my shorts pull any liners out I don't
have to do any of that crazy [ __ ] yeah
you don't need to do that at that moment
because you already did that like you've
already explained how [ __ ] dumb you
are and how [ __ ] foul you are so
don't try to like make the whole
situation better by going I don't have
another one or not because you already
did it dude I and then right after done
right after
I hand fed these spamazooies
I would not allow it I've been with you
for two for too long
remember that time David will never drop
this memory
but remember what were you doing
you we were grilling oh you were
grilling in the backyard feeders are
always cover a charcoal and they were
just [ __ ] it looked like you were
like working a [ __ ] coal mine or
something yeah like [ __ ] in a coal
mine or something and your nails and
your hands were disgusting and then you
come in and you're like hey babe you
want to try this piece of steak and I
was like what the [ __ ] what was it good
though I did not eat it
you know I didn't eat it you're [ __ ]
your hygiene is [ __ ] interesting hey
once you've been in the military
sometimes your hygiene standards are
like it doesn't really matter honestly
so like I do talk this [ __ ] right but
like going back to your example of like
[ __ ] hitting the fan
I mean I think I can easily Just Adjust
all of that like if I have to wipe my
ass with my hand only like I'm going
because I I'm a female and I'm supposed
to do that but in the back of my mind
I'm like I mean I'll do what I need to
do would you let me pee in your mouth
why what's the point of it it needs to
make sense you need water
if I'm dying yeah probably
wow I'm trying to live you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah like that's why I
think we'd make a really good
consummated you no I okay like if do you
want me to be a female or do you want me
to be a survivor
because those are gonna I'm gonna give
you two they're yielding two different
answers here the Survivor outfit sounds
hotter though
what's the other Survivor outfit I don't
know like some [ __ ]
Tarzana type [ __ ] yeah but you know
what's really going to be some
loincloths I'm gonna have the bushiest
[ __ ] cooch the stinkiest cooch the
stinkiest pitch why are they so stinky
because I'm in survivor mode what do you
think I'm gonna be taking a shower
[ __ ] twice a day will you be swimming
every day probably where where's the
water where am I swimming right there
we're in Vegas dude where what are we
talking about like me oh God
yeah so your Survivor to the real
Survivor are two completely different
things surviving in Hawaii
you probably smell nice
smell like your coconut kissed
[Laughter]
Ben let's go to Hawaii first so we can
keep your [ __ ] your dick hard
oh my God your face is so stupid
you know what's really CUNY about us
what
um today I was I was scrolling through
Instagram yeah and um I follow like nine
gags like eight facts or eight some
facts [ __ ] that they have you know mine
guy has like a million different
channels yeah
um and they they said that research
shows that couples that can have like
innocent banter between each other uh
tend to have happier and stronger
relationships yeah that's kidney you did
know that no but I've always had that
gut feeling where I'm like if you're a
partner can be your best friend and you
can be like your person that you just
share a life with
um
I Think You're Gonna Last way longer
really because I don't think at least
traditionally
like our parents and older I don't think
they shared lives
you know what I mean
uh
um yeah it's really traditional I get it
where it's like stay at home mom
working dad
and the working dad has working dad
friends stay at home mom has stay at
home mom friends if friends even yeah
and then it's two lives that come
together yeah and then the only shared
uh relationship they have is a family
life yeah yeah and then uh maybe like
um from that generation became one of
the females started working more it was
just two professionals
and they don't really
um
share life it's just two people coming
together
and then I think in this generation you
start having like people that are like
oh we're but we're gonna be doctors
together and work in the same hospital
or two people we're going to open a
business we're both going to run this
Airbnb
so I think now we're seeing like what
more and more of like people actually
sharing lives yes because I think like
to be separate
and to share lives it can be done but
you got to be like really good at
communicating ever since you're a kid
you know people are just really
vulnerable and they can share stuff with
you because there's also like the uh I
would say like the quintessential
military wife
that is a stay at home but she knows all
of the dudes co-workers will even plan
surprise birthdays for them you know and
then they're all tight like that they're
part of like the Military Wives Club so
it's possible but it takes a lot of
effort
um to share lives yeah
and so like but any type of aspect we
could share life and you can have banter
I think it's for sure you're gonna be
way better yeah yeah yeah
um I kind of saw it a little bit diff I
mean similar but like kind of different
um similar because yeah the the whole
friend aspect of it it's like
um I know couples where they're not each
other's best friends
and that's not bad it's just a different
it's just a different approach to it but
if you really can't mess with each other
then it's
for me the way I see it I'm just like
dang how stiff is this relationship like
were you kind of like you can't just
[ __ ] around like it has you're always
kind of like walking on eggshells like
oh [ __ ]
I don't know
yeah yeah it just it just um
um I didn't really think about it much
as like what you were saying in terms of
like uh there's a working mom and the
work I didn't really think about all of
that stuff because I don't know if that
really I mean obviously it's going to
play a a role in it but I don't know if
that really matters
you know what I mean
I think it does really yeah like
you know like um like let's say you have
the best friend like you don't you're
you're significant other doesn't have to
be your best voice but they got to be
your life friend
you know like if you have a a movie that
just comes out and the first person you
want to watch it with is someone else
or you eat something bomb you're like
dude I can't wait to share this with
someone else
then um there's too many things that's
pulling you away from what could be a
potential opportunity to constantly
cultivate
you know I mean like I can't wait to
watch everything with you even my
favorite things that I know you hate I
still want to do it with you like one
day I would love for both of us like me
going scuba diving with the best scuba
diver in the whole world versus your
claustrophobic ass if I could get you
underwater some someday and we just you
even saying that right now my I can't
make it but like if we witness a kelp
floors together one day and we see beams
of light come in like I'd be like oh my
God I'd be so [ __ ] happy because I
shared it with you yeah you know to be
dope what it's like I went to like my
favorite like fashion house and I'm
trying on all these beautiful dresses
and then I look over and so are you oh
my God I'm just kidding yeah so like to
me
um
it it gives it more room and it leans
towards like the relationship could be
super strong you know yeah
for me I see I see
yeah
the older so I think back in the day I'd
be like yeah because I would see it like
that but the older I've gotten in the
more
um I've leaned into like motherhood and
just wife Hood
um I realize how important and dope it
is to not have like the same shared
thing you know what I mean I understand
what you're saying is is
um always wanting to live life with your
partner and having those experiences be
with them first because now like you can
cultivate it or whatever but for me I'm
going like
um I think it's
if if your partner is obviously to make
things stronger right like your partner
even if they don't like something it
you're going to be so grateful you're
gonna feel so much love that if you know
that I'm cluster clusterphobic but I'm
still down to go with you it's like I'm
putting my own [ __ ] aside for you so
obviously that's gonna make you feel
super um super loved
um but then would be dope is if you know
my claustrophobic ass and as I'm
fighting to go with you and you're
fighting for me to stay I think that's
really CUNY yeah that's CUNY yeah I
think Separate Lives is good too yeah
you know because I think that's
definitely healthy
but then I'm just comparing like the
stereotypical where the dude is already
something else like let's say he's a
construction worker right yeah he his
his him and his wife's lives are
completely separate after work comes
home eats dinner then he's like okay now
I'm gonna go bowling with the boys or
whatever yeah and then gone again and
then grab beers with the boys and then
like Sundays or Mondays watch the
football game with the boys phew yeah
right it's just
there's a lot of Separation versus like
these days I see like yeah it is for the
community these days yeah I'll see like
uh like couples both watching the sports
games together because they're equal
fans they both got jerseys they're both
like that to me is cool it's like shared
life you know yeah yeah I do agree yeah
yeah I have seen that now more than ever
yeah
um like my dad's generation like they
weren't the dads to like take care of
kids like that yeah you know what I mean
like I'm sure your dad probably didn't
take care of you yeah no he barely
that's why even when he was like holding
like taika and stuff he's like
huh
you know I mean for how you're
describing it he actually was pretty
pretty obviously there's some holes in
it but he's also a man and from an older
generation so I'm like oh okay I get it
yeah um but yeah he was really good with
taika
but yeah that generation with kids just
it they they were different dads whereas
now like I like you still sing the same
song to taika that you did when he was
like days old
ABC's yeah yeah like that was that was
your idea you know and
um I didn't grow up seeing that [ __ ] so
like when you started doing it I was
like whoa this is so tight like this is
a partnership [ __ ] yeah it was pretty
sick I was just trying to make them
smart it was my the Asian side of me two
plus two equals four four plus two
equals six six times two equals uh I'm
just kidding pretty good
yeah that's what we should have been
teaching his ass yeah a little dude
but yeah so when I read that I just
wanted to write like duh because it's
just so obvious you know that if you can
banter and have a good time and just be
a kid with your partner then just the
relationship is that much sweeter and
like and it also it also shows that
you're not insecure about things to be
so defensive about it you know like
there's so many times that you talk so
much [ __ ] to me you know like that's
actually how some of the best
friendships were made
so they're made in the suck
right like whether you're like both
deployed or some [ __ ] or you are uh both
in a hardcore Championship sports game
that Badger the locker room dancer or
the bus banter or even the banter on the
field like being able to like chit chat
about the most mundane things but then
have that Rapport it really solidifies
how tight you guys are yeah and then how
much how much you guys can overcome
um whatever hardships together yeah like
if you're my friend and I can't call you
a stupid [ __ ] without feeling bad then
um we're probably not really that close
friends yeah like all my male friends
and all my female friends I can call
them stupid [ __ ]
um and they'll never think I'm calling
them a stupid [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah yeah they just know that I'm just
calling them a stupid [ __ ] that's very
different yeah yeah but my non-wheel
real real friends I'd be like Oh I'm not
gonna even write the word [ __ ] that's
when they know if they're like we're
really tired or not if I can call them a
[ __ ] you just throw it out there and
see what happens
or do you kind of know I feel before you
say it yeah I feel it because if I'm
like hesitant to even put it out there
I'm like oh we're not there yet so
you'll be like oh [ __ ] I think we just
hit the [ __ ] moment yeah yeah yeah
but once I could really say stupid [ __ ]
um then I know we're good
yeah
just I think you're just a big CUNY oh
thank you yeah I love our relationship I
love relationship too even though you
like turkey you [ __ ] like
Thanksgiving I mean those are things I
could just
Overlook anything you're looking forward
to this Christmas since Christmas is
your banger
um
uh sadly
sadly this Christmas is gonna kinda have
to be like a little low Pro Christmas
just because we're in the middle of a
move yeah so because of that like we're
still living out of boxes but
on the positive side of that I'm always
looking forward to just spending time
with my family and just seeing them and
and just seeing the kids open up
presents and stuff like Christmas if we
really look at it is is about
togetherness but it's ultimately about
like the kids and [ __ ] and like how they
still believe in this magic of like
Santa and like reindeers and like they
put the [ __ ] the the celery stick out
and the cookies in the milk because
Santa's like real you know so like that
magic part of it is something I always
forget about because I'm just an old ass
[ __ ] now yeah
um but like now going through these old
school traditions and reliving them with
taika I'm like oh yeah I forgot all
about this [ __ ] is so cool so yeah I'm
looking forward to that part of it
seeing magic and the Hope Through The
Eyes of children there's like nothing
like it you know you're just like
the world is beautiful
it's very cute it is really CUNY all
right papa bear is there anything else
you wanna you wanna add
no turkey soup oh actually wait no come
on stop it um what what are you looking
forward to this Christmas sorry
I don't know
um we have so many things
um all over the place so many moving
parts
so I don't even know what we're doing
this Christmas yet yeah like um my heart
of hearts is like I'm kind of split
right now because I do want to get this
house settled and I would love to spend
Christmas here because Vegas is just
nice and cold and it just like it feels
like more seasonal yeah and then people
are still very festive here so a lot
more people will decorate their houses
and stuff and um compare to LA
or at least our areas of La yeah
um
but our family is in Ellie and like you
said Christmas is about family
so I do want I do like the coziness of
family together too
so I guess we'll just we'll just see
we'll just figure it out like we've been
trying to figure out the last couple of
months damn why do you feel like you've
been through some [ __ ] been through the
last couple of months I've been through
some [ __ ] and if you're not caught up
for sure watch the last
um
episode last episode before this one
because the last couple of months have
been be right uh
and a bumpy ass ride man how we're still
standing I don't know honestly it's no
it's pretty [ __ ] up I'm like it's not
even that crazy
but I think I'm in denial I always think
that like uh you know that saying like
God only gives you what you can handle
yes and I'm always like man you must
think I'm strong bro yeah I can't handle
that much buddy it's the last couple of
months
have been [ __ ] crazy especially one
of the middle things you know what I'm
talking about some of some of us do know
what you're talking about yeah so you
gotta go listen
because uh if you've been wondering Hey
where's your dad at we talk about that
anyway
yeah on that note
um anything you you would like to close
it out with nope thank god oh I do
actually I do I do because I've been
working really [ __ ] hard on it and um
I probably should have shared this like
a week earlier but I don't want to
um just because of the sereness of the
yeah the last the last episode
but I know a lot of people look forward
to this time of year because Black
Friday sales are nuts and so this is our
biggest event of the year at borrow
Brigade so make sure you go check it out
um I don't want to get the dates wrong
because we're starting Black Friday just
a little bit earlier so people don't
have to wait till midnight but uh Black
Friday starts November
24th at 7 pm Pacific Standard Time go to
bottlebrigade.com and apparel is 25 to
75 off certain things
and uh supplements best time to stock up
because all of them are buy one get one
half off all digital programs you've
been wanting to grab get started get
lean all of those are 25 off
and uh if we still have a few mystery
boxes left because I know some people
are already left out those are 25 bucks
uh 25 off and that's crazy because the
mystery box for 100 bucks you'll get 200
worth of stuff now we're getting 25 off
of that so 75 gets you 200 worth of
stuff I don't think any of these things
are going to last very long so go to
bottlebrigade.com
um I know a lot of you guys like to
stock up on a ton of barbell stuff tag
me and all of your guys's posts because
you guys always tag me and it makes me
so happy when I see people like have the
whole collection yeah I got the knee
sleeves so sick so tag me
um and I know you guys like to stock up
so I want to give you guys all the
discounts so you guys can get as much as
you want yeah
so on that note thank you guys so much
for listening watching tuning in I'm so
happy to be back oh can't wait for the
holidays and uh yeah see you guys next
week
bye